he's Marvel's first mutant bane of
wakanda and Adolf Hitler's worst
nightmare this is Neymar the Submariner
Neymar first appeared in 1939's Marvel
Comics number one in which he is
established as an enemy of humanity from
the very beginning in his underwater
Kingdom Neymar comes upon two salvage
divers who he is convinced are robots
due to their strange Garb he kills both
divers and brings their bodies back to
his people once he peels the diver suits
off his victims revealing they weren't
robots after all his mother in
particular Praises Neymar for what he's
done she tells him humans almost caused
their kind to go completely extinct and
that she has long meant to wreak
vengeance upon them by the time he gets
his own series with the 1941's
Submariner Comics number one Neymar's
Vengeance has become focused on the
Nazis Hitler orders Neymar's undersea
home bombarded by U-boats killing many
of his people including the emperor
Submariner Comics Number Four was
published just a month before the
bombing of Pearl Harbor and when
Submariner Comics Number 5 was released
in late 1942 Neymar had made the
Japanese his new targets sadly the
subsequent stories didn't exactly Mark
Marvel's finest moments like many comics
of the time Submariner Comics featured
offensive depictions of the Japanese
they're so bad in fact that Neymar's old
colleague Spitfire comments on them as
she browses through a stack of old
comics in 1991's Namor the Submariner
number 19. if you haven't heard of
Neymar there's a good chance it's
because he's so often overshadowed by DC
Comics more well-known aquatic hero
Aquaman the two have a lot in common
they're both underwater Heroes both are
the product of a union between humans
and fictional undersea people and each
is the heir to the throne of his
respective version of Atlantis even
though they've both worked on the side
of the Angels they also each tend to
Harbor at least some sense of antagonism
towards the surface World though Neymar
clearly dominates in that department all
of this has led to the false belief that
the Submariner is merely a clone of his
more popular DC counterpart in fact if
anything it's the other way around the
Submariner first showed up in 1939 while
Aquaman didn't surface until more fun
Comics number 73 which was released in
1941 Aquaman undoubtedly enjoyed more
Fame than Neymar over the years even
beating him to the Silver Screen I am
the protector of the team
I am
Aquaman
still there's no need to point fingers
the 30s and 40s saw comic book
publishers trying any and every gimmick
they could think of it isn't that much
of a stretch to assume two different
comic book creators could have conceived
of similar aquatic Heroes without ever
seeing one another's work
Namor the Submariner was the creation of
Bill Everett who was reportedly a
descendant of the poet William Blake
poetry had a key role in the creation of
the character too Everett's daughter
Wendy once said in an interview that
Neymar was based on the rhyme of the
Ancient Mariner by Samuel Taylor
Coleridge she explained Everett had red
Coleridge and this background gave the
characters a very erudite wholeness in
tribute to the character's Origins and
inspiration 1993's Namor the Submariner
number 44 Loosely adapted coleridge's
poem for the comic book page Everett
conceived of the Submariner while
working for funnies Inc the character
was initially planned as part of a
promotional comic that would be given to
moviegoers at theaters that idea was
scrapped however and instead Everett
used it for Marvel Comics number one the
hero was a hit and Everett would go on
to write and draw Submariner stories in
a number of other titles Everett took a
break from Neymar for many decades but
eventually returned to his stories he
ultimately ended up writing and drawing
the character until the end of his life
working on Neymar's story entails to
astonish and Submariner in the late 60s
and early 70s Everett passed away in
February 1973 Submariner number 61
Everett's final issue was published a
few months later I'm here to talk to you
about the Avenger initiative these days
Marvel Comics has no end of line wide
events which draw together heroes from
all over its Universe even though
reading the whole story usually means
spending more money crossovers remain
popular part of the reason they still
sell is because they affirm the idea
that Marvel's fans are plugged into a
large complex fictional world and it
could be argued that Namor helped create
it many superhero comics in the Golden
Age of the 1930s and 40s were
anthologies rather than featuring
stories of one hero they were roughly
three times longer than a modern comic
book and offered readers multiple
stories each one starring a different
character in 1940s Marvel Mystery Comics
Number 8 through 10 two of the title's
heroes Neymar and Jim Hammond the
original Human Torch meat and lockhorns
in battle this meeting confirmed that
their stories took place in the same
world and is often considered to be the
story that established what we now call
the Marvel Universe
one of the more contentious debates fans
fielded over the years is whether or not
Neymar is a mutant he was after all born
with his powers and not all of his
abilities can be explained by his shared
Atlantean Heritage for example while
atlanteans are naturally stronger than
humans Namor is even stronger also Namor
can fly which is not an ability most
atlanteans share on the other hand one
major Marvel crossover seemed to counter
the argument that he's a mutant in the
1996 line wide event Onslaught Namor is
among the many Heroes to sacrifice
themselves in order to defeat the
villain Onslaught by charging into him
after the Hulk cracks his armor when
this happens in Onslaught Marvel
Universe number one it said that this is
only an option for non-mutant Heroes
because Onslaught would be able to
possess any Mutant who tried it well
Onslaught is defeated and Namor isn't
possessed regardless of past
inconsistencies however Neymar's mutant
Origins are now set in stone he even
joins the X-Men in the 2012 line wide
event Avengers vs X-Men having a year
earlier enjoyed a brief solo title Namor
the first mutant recently he was invited
to join the rest of Earth's mutants on
the mutant island of krakowa as part of
the dawn of X event but declined
no you didn't see him fight the Nazis in
Captain America the First Avenger but in
the comics the Submariner was right
there alongside Steve Rogers and his
allies as they attempted to lend some
superhuman weight to the struggle
against fascism wait you know what
you're doing yeah I've knocked that
Adolf Hitler over 200 times
the World War II era team was originally
called the all-winner squad but this was
later retconned now the team that helped
retake Europe from Hitler is known as
the Invaders ironically the team has
enjoyed more modern comic book
appearances than they did during the
Golden Age of comics before the 60s the
Invaders only appeared together in two
1946 issues of all winners comics in
more recent years though there have been
multiple limited and ongoing series that
revived the team in one form or another
not to mention extensive flashbacks and
different issues of Captain America as
recently as 2019 Marvel released a new
Invaders series which sees Neymar's old
teammates try to stop him from Waging
War on the surface world one more time
superheroes fell out of fashion after
World War II but when Marvel got back
into the cape business in the 60s the
company didn't forget its roots even
before bringing Captain America back
into the fold Marvel established the
return of the Submariner right away it
was clear that the Marvel universe's
citizens wouldn't welcome Neymar quite
as much as they would Steve Rogers in
1962's Fantastic Four number four Johnny
Storm intervenes when he sees a group of
men harassing an amnesiac homeless man
when the angry men offered to beat the
memory out of him Johnny shocks them by
revealing that he's the Human Torch the
comic then gives us what if the most
iconic images of the Silver age the
human torch giving a homeless man a
fiery shave and learning that he is
actually the Submariner it turns out
that this encounter isn't enough to jog
The Aquatic hero's memory so Johnny
flies him over the city and drops him
into the ocean correctly assuming that
the return to his natural environment
will awaken his memory unfortunately in
doing so the Human Torch accidentally
creates one of the Fantastic Four's
greatest foes the submariner's first act
upon regaining his memory is to summon a
giant sea monster to lay Siege to
Manhattan thus ensues the first of many
battles between Namor and the Fantastic
Four
I have never known a female like you
although Namor has more recently become
the Nemesis of wakanda the character has
remained most closely associated with
Marvel's first family the fish man and
the Fantastic Four have duped it out
across multiple comic book titles while
their Feud has been depicted in animated
shows and video games unsurprisingly
Reed Richards and the Gang consider
Neymar to be one of their most dangerous
foes the king of Atlantis however wants
only one thing from the Superhero Squad
Sue storms love Reed and Sue's marriage
can get Rocky at times and the invisible
woman has been known to flirt around
with Marvel studs such as black panther
however the connection between Neymar
and Sue seems to go much deeper than
that as the Atlantean has always pined
for his fantastic foe while Sue often
runs to the Sea whenever marriage
troubles arise although it is not
confirmed if Sue has ever officially
cheated with Namor they doubtless share
an emotional attachment one that never
bodes well for the Fantastic Four in the
days leading up to Civil War it was
revealed that a group of superheroes
known only as the the Illuminati had
been working behind the scenes ever
since the cree scroll war in 2006's New
Avengers Illuminati we see the meeting
that brings together Iron Man Doctor
Strange Mr Fantastic Black Bolt
Professor X and neymore to form this
clandestine group black panther is the
sole invitee to decline although he
joins years later when the group reforms
in New Avengers welcoming a few new
members at the same time from the
beginning Neymar is one of the loudest
voices of descent and it's partly
because of his objections to Iron Man's
initial Vision that their group goes
underground one of the group's more
infamously terrible decisions is the
Exile of Bruce Banner from Earth which
leads to the events of Planet Hulk and
its explosive sequel World War Hulk
just hate us Bruce
but you always said you wanted to be
left alone
finally find peace while Namor is often
considered to be the least intelligent
and most hot-headed member of the
Illuminati in this case he's the only
member to vote against Banner's Exile
and arguably the only one to make the
right choice the dispute over this issue
explodes into a fist fight between Namor
and Iron Man and ends with the
Submariner prophesying Banner's return
along with the Hulk and Doctor Strange
Namor the Submariner was one of the
founding members of The Defenders the
superhero team founded in 1971's Marvel
feature number one in fact even before
the Defenders were formed submariner's
Adventures were pivotal in laying its
foundations in 1971 Roy Thomas wrote the
two-part Titans three story in
Submariner number 34 and 35 the tale
United Namor Hulk and Silver Surfer and
in a 2013 interview with back issue
Thomas said that these were the three
Heroes he originally wanted to beat the
Defenders he replaced Silver Surfer with
Doctor Strange because of Stan Lee's
insistence that no one should write the
surfer but lead between 1971 and 1972
named a more Hulk and strange appeared
as the defenders in Marvel feature
number one through three and finally in
1972's Defenders number one the lineup
remained unchanged for only a single
issue after which when Stan the Man
apparently changed his mind and the
Silver Surfer joined the team in the
early issues of Defenders Neymar often
warns his teammates to not bother
calling him for help again ironically
despite his objections he continues to
help them out over the years including
in the 2018 mini event the best defense
Neymar has a few powers that don't show
up much in the comics everyone knows he
can fly he has super strength and
obviously he can breathe underwater but
that's certainly not the limit of his
amazing abilities one such ability is
his electric eel power Namor can direct
electricity through his body from an
outside source and blast an opponent
with it we see him use this power for
the first time against Dr Doom in 1962's
Fantastic Four number six and he also
uses it against the Human Torch in
Strange Tales number 107. many years
later in the middle of a cover to cover
brawl with the Hulk in 1977's Defenders
number 52 the Submariner uses the power
again it disappears once more until
2002's the order number three when
Neymar redirects one of the wasp's
bioelectric bolts at her teammate
Captain America more recently Neymar has
revealed a new power control over water
this new ability made its arguably
non-canon debut in the 2001 miniseries
Fantastic Four one two three four but
returned in 2019 for Invaders In which
Neymar reveals that he has stolen in
this power from hydroman thanks to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe audiences are
quite familiar with one of the comic
universe's most powerful weapons The
Infinity Gauntlet holding the six
Infinity Stones The Gauntlet becomes a
conduit capable of destroying half of
the universe in actuality the weapon is
capable of nearly anything as it can
bend times souls and even reality itself
what did it cost
[Music]
everything
understandably this kind of power would
be tempting for anybody and especially
for a king who dreams of ruling the
entire world however when Namor had the
opportunity to take The Infinity
Gauntlet complete with all six infinity
gems he actually passed it up Namor the
Submariner was given the chance to pick
up the all-powerful glove in the 2015
comic event Secret Wars in this story
Namor and black panther discover The
Infinity Gauntlet on a secret Island
thankfully the Submariner is self-aware
enough to know that he would inevitably
use the weapon for evil black panther
slides on The Gauntlet himself and uses
it to attack Dr Doom in the event's
final battle
Neymar has spent decades proving his
capacity for heroism he has fought
alongside the X-Men the Defenders The
Avengers The Fantastic Four and even
with the Invaders against the Nazis but
there is no place on Marvel's Earth
where the name Neymar is more synonymous
with villainy than in the African nation
of wakanda twice in the past decade or
so Neymar has directly contributed to
massive cataclysms in wakanda invariably
leading to thousands of deaths in 2012's
Avengers vs X-Men line white event Namor
is one of the five mutants who make up
the Phoenix 5 along with Cyclops Emma
Frost Colossus and Magic Namor is imbued
with part of the Phoenix Force when
Namor tracks The Avengers to wakanda he
uses his Newfound power and his armies
to unleash the ocean on wakanda
murdering Untold numbers of wakandans
two years later in New Avengers number
23 Neymar betrays the Illuminati and
helps form the cabal a group made up
mostly a villain such as Thanos and
Maximus the Mad together they slaughter
a number of alternate Earths in order to
save the prime Marvel reality and they
also conquer wakanda leading to among
other things the death of shuri Namor
eventually turns on the cabal but
neither the people of wakanda nor black
panther forgive him for his crimes
though the comic book version of Neymar
has enjoyed a reputation as a defender
of the earth his first outing in Black
Panther wakanda forever leans more into
his villainous history with the people
of wakanda the Submariner is set to make
his live-action debut in Black Panther
wakanda forever his arrival on screen
has been a long time coming much longer
than you might think in fact
surprisingly there have been talks about
making a live-action adaptation of
Neymar's story since the 1950s
originally intended to Star Richard Egan
a Submariner series was to be produced
in 1955 off the heels of the successful
Superman TV show
look up in the sky it's a bird it's
Superman yes it's Superman unfortunately
the series never made it to air the king
of Atlantis almost made his big screen
debut in 1997 when talks began for a
movie directed by Philip Kaufman this
film adaptation would be bounced around
among Studios writers and directors for
several years before nearly being
realized in 2004 although the Neymar
movie was still in early production
until 2009 the film failed to
materialize with universal and
possession of the characters film rights
the MCU was unable to bring one of its
oldest characters to the big screen
until contracts were clarified in 2018.
finally the Submariner was nearly
included as a member of the Illuminati
in 2022's doctor strange and the
Multiverse of Madness by then though
Marvel Studios already had plans for the
character black panther wakanda forever
was chosen as the setting for the
submariner's debut in the MCU that said
there are a few key differences between
this version of Namor and the one who
exists in the comic books for one thing
the team behind wakanda forever have
decided to adapt Atlantis into a
mesoamerican-themed aquatic Kingdom
called talokin former Marvel artist
Anthony Francisco told Looper that the
inspiration for the Atlantis redesign
came after watching a documentary about
mesoamerica he said I was thinking how
do I put technology together with the
folklore and the gods into what Namor is
and the civilization underneath these
designs have helped add one more Nation
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
with Neymar's long-awaited arrival it's
likely that the taloken people are sure
to make a splash in a number of other
upcoming MCU projects
[Music]